my name is sergei lysenko I used to be  investigative journalist and in year  2014 I was elected as a member of  parliament from party list of block /  schenker now I remember of  anti-corruption committee empowerment  Ukrainian citizens where am I done  because of European values it's not very  often in Europe now when you can find  such strong euro optimism but Ukrainians  want to be part of European civilization  a part of European society part of  European Union Maidan demonstrated that  society is ready for changes  in Parliament we adopt a lot of very  positive legislation regarding  anti-corruption measures starting from  established anti-corruption Bureau which  going to be the main enforcement body to  fight with corruption second we adopted  legislation on political finance of  political parties and parties in Ukraine  will be financed from government from  state budget and this is a typical  European practice when parties have  alternative money for all you guys